[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
DAVID BENSON: Please, everybody.
Please, grab a seat.
So first off, welcome.
OWEN SLOT: Thank you.
DAVID BENSON: And thank
you for coming to Google.
Great turn out, especially on a
sunny day with a train strike.
It's normally a good
excuse to stay at home.
But you've obviously
got the draw.
So just sort of, for
everyone in the room,
Owen Slot has been the
Chief Rugby Correspondent
for "The Times" since 2015.
But before stepping
into this role,
he was the chief
"Times" sports reporter.
And the roles overlapped.
And that really
allowed him to cover
the Rio Olympics,
which was, what,
six summer games in succession?
OWEN SLOT: Six on
the trot, yeah.
DAVID BENSON: Pretty impressive.
Going back to Atlanta in 1996--
so given the average
age of Google,
I think that's probably
when most Googlers were
being born at the time.
And so he's reported over those
Olympics and three Winter Games
as well.
So it was really sort
of seeing that success
of the great British Olympic
team over 20 years that
inspired him to write
this amazing book.
But he did want me to
tell you that he has not
come close to winning an
Olympic medal himself,
although did compete for the
Dorking under-16 tennis team
and was Dorking champion,
I believe, so fantastic.
OWEN SLOT: Proud moment.
[LAUGHTER]
DAVID BENSON: So,
Owen, I want everybody
to not just hear about
what's in the book.
You should all buy the book.
That's a solid
recommendation from me.
But, also, to sort of hear a
bit about the story around it
and some of the big
outtakes you had from it.
So perhaps you
could just kick off
with what really inspired you
to write "The Talent Lab."
OWEN SLOT: Sure.
So the first Olympic Games I
went to as a reporter was '96.
And I was 28 years old.
And it was sort of
the culmination,
or it was my ambition,
as a sports reporter,
to go to one of these things.
And going to Olympics is
an amazing experience.
And I don't know if many people
experienced that in London
in 2012, but a great
thing to be a part of.
So I went there as a journalist.
And there were no
great expectations
for the British team.
And the British team won one
gold medal at those games.
I said there were no
great expectations,
but that was lower
than anyone had really
considered at the time.
And it was pretty rubbish.
And there were smaller
nations, like North Korea, that
did better than Great Britain.
And this was all
part of the story.
And it was a classic case of old
British mores in elite sport,
if you like, as in we were--
I say we, but the team were--
amateur-based.
The athletes all had jobs
outside of their sport.
So they were competing against
full-time professionals.
They were happy
amateurs, if you like.
There was no great ambition
to do better than that.
And they got what they
deserved, if you like,
finished 36th on
the medal table.
And as a journalist, it
was a good story to cover,
because it was so poor.
I remember one day, one
of the stories at the end
was the two members of
the diving team had set up
a shop, a sort of
pop-up shop on the side
of the main street in Atlanta.
And they were selling their kit.
And this was like a
sort of a metaphor
for Great Britain, the
paupers of the Olympic world.
It didn't go down too well with
the management, funnily enough.
But so anyway, so I saw '96.
And then lottery money
came in after that.
And then I just had
the best position
to witness the phenomenal
growth from there to there.
So '96 one gold medal.
2012, Great Britain
won 27 gold medals.
And '96, there was a total of
one female British medalist
at all.
Denise Lewis won a
bronze in the heptathlon.
And then Rio Games,
20 years later,
the number of British women
to win a medal of any kind
was 58, so 1 to 58.
And so I'd seen
this, what I thought,
was one of the great
transformations,
a great transformational
story in sport,
one of the sort of great
success stories in sport.
And it was partly
inspired by the money,
but I sort of got to learn how
they did it and what drove it.
And I just thought that that's
one of the great stories
and went to the people
involved and said, listen,
we've got to do a book on this.
DAVID BENSON: Yeah.
I mean, it's interesting
you should say that.
Because, whenever I was going
around, say, drumming up
a bit of sport saying,
look, this is a great book,
and everybody went,
well, of course,
we won the medals,
because we put money in.
OWEN SLOT: Yeah.
DAVID BENSON: But
that's not true, is it?
OWEN SLOT: Well,
so it's the start.
So that is the natural
reaction, and it's not
an incorrect reaction either.
So before money--
Great Britain 36th
on the medal table.
Rio-- second on the medal table.
So one of the questions for
the book which I try to tackle
is, if you just
chuck money at it,
does that guarantee
your success.
Is it just a straightforward
money equals medals equation?
And my answer is
very, very much no.
So we don't know how much for--
so in Great Britain, we
publish an audited account
of how much is spent on every
single sport, every year,
so we know exactly what it is.
And funnily enough,
Russia and China
don't do the same sort of
thing on a public basis.
[LAUGHTER]
But we're pretty sure that
they outspend Great Britain,
considerably.
But one of the great
achievements of Rio
was that Great Britain
finished above both those two
traditional Olympic superpowers.
And then, if you compare
Great Britain to,
for instance, one of our great
sporting rivals Australia--
who over the '90s and early
00's were ahead of Great Britain
on the medal table.
For the Rio Olympics,
Great Britain,
if you total what was
spent on the elite team,
over the four years,
going into the games,
Great Britain outspent
Australia by 37%,
but beat them on the
medal table by 131%.
One of the other comparisons I
like is, if you put together,
on a similar basis,
Japan and South Korea,
who do have very exact
accounts of what they spend--
if you put together what they
spent leading into the London
Games, they spent seven times
what Great Britain spent.
Yet, on the medal
table, Great Britain
matched those two put together,
so sort of seven times
more effective.
So sort of what I argue in
the book is having the money,
having the lottery funding,
allows talented kids
opportunities to do well.
But it doesn't make
them take them.
DAVID BENSON: Yeah.
Amazing.
I mean, you just
sort of mentioned
that sort of Russia and China
are big Olympic superpowers
but not very transparent.
You know, one of the amazing
things about this book
is you have so much access.
There's so much revealed
about how we did it.
OWEN SLOT: Yeah.
DAVID BENSON: How did
you get that access?
And how did you get all
these people to talk to you
about their secrets of success?
OWEN SLOT: Well, yes, I
was slightly surprised.
So in the years of build
up-- so as a reporter,
I did a lot of Olympic sports
reporting in the lead up
to the Athens Games in '04
and then Beijing in '08.
So at that point,
we knew that London
were going to get the games.
So as a reporter,
I thought, right,
I'm just going to be
on the Olympic story,
because it's the
big sports story.
And so during that
time, I got to know
some of the people who
worked for UK Sport, which
is kind of like the central
funding hub for all Olympics
sports.
Well, they decide
where to invest.
They're, in a sense, a bit like
sort of an investment bank,
also management consultants
at the same time.
So they're trying to
work out what businesses
to stick their money into, where
they're going to get a return.
And they're also trying to
manage it at the same time.
And they have all sorts
of different businesses,
the big successful ones and
the start-ups, if you like.
So I got to know who
people ran them quite well.
And it became quite
clear to me that they
had phenomenal knowledge that
wasn't being reported much
in the newspapers, that they
were cutting-edge globally
in terms of the
knowledge and the smarts
and the skill sets they took
to managing sports teams.
I mean, talent ID
was the first thing
that I sort of started
writing about with them.
And at the time, talent ID
was almost like a dirty word,
in sport, in Great Britain.
When they announced that they
were going to do a talent ID
scheme, I kid you
not, there were
newspapers that were
comparing it to East Germany.
And it was like the
old East Germany,
which was sort of the dark days
of how not to run a sporting
system.
And so they were brave,
and they were cutting edge.
And in the lead-up to the London
Games, I was saying to them,
listen, what you're doing
is clever and impressive.
And the story of your
growth and successes
is staggering as well.
So I think it's a great story.
And they were going,
yeah, but we'd
like to keep it to ourselves.
[LAUGHTER]
And I guess I was lucky that I
managed to win some confidences
and to make some friends.
And at the same time,
around the weeks and months
after the London Games, there
was a change in management.
And there was a
new sports director
called Simon Timson,
who was pretty gung-ho,
a really good bloke, but
sort of liked to be out there
and was quite happy
for people to know
about what they were doing.
Also, at the same
time, you may remember
there was a big concern.
So lots of funding had gone
into British Olympic sport
up to London.
And there was a
big concern that,
after London-- sort of
London had happened.
We'd done it.
It had been a success--
that funding would drop off.
And so they were quite
happy for their skills
and their abilities to
be promoted a bit more.
And so thus, the book.
They generally have taken
the book to sports ministers
and funding people in
Parliament and saying, listen,
this is what we do.
And this is why we do it well.
And it was also seen as a
way of trying to get support.
So they eventually said, yes.
Then the publisher said yes.
And then we had this
sort of magical sort
of two years where I would
go into the UK Sport offices
once a month.
And with the two leading
people in UK Sport--
Simon Timson was one and Chelsea
Warr, who was his deputy--
every session, we'd target
either a sport or a theme.
So it could be swimming.
Or it could be leadership.
Or it could be gymnastics.
Or it could be how
to stay successful.
We'd talk sort of all
the way through the story
of how they saw swimming and
whether it was doing well
or what it was trying to do.
And then, at the
end of the session,
we'd have a list
of names of coaches
and performance directors,
psychologists, or whatever.
And then over the
next couple of days,
they'd be copying me into
emails with those people.
And then I'd be following up.
And then I'd be going to the
swimming people and saying,
can I come and see you.
So I sort of created
a very long journey
that started at UK Sport.
And then I'd get to see
more and more people.
And--
DAVID BENSON: So you
sort of gradually
worked your way into the system.
OWEN SLOT: Yeah,
and just accumulated
more and more information.
And for sure, there
were some people
that felt awkward about
sharing their information.
And for sure, that there's only
a limit to where I've gone.
And there's,
obviously, areas where
they didn't want
the public to see
or their competitors to see.
But I think-- well,
as you said, I
think they were quite
open with what they've
allowed to go out there.
DAVID BENSON: Yeah.
Well, I think you've
certainly created
almost a manual of how to build
an Olympic team, quite frankly.
It's a great place to start.
But, you know, just to put
the achievement into context,
so normally teams do
well in their home games
and then decline.
OWEN SLOT: Yeah.
DAVID BENSON: We didn't.
We did better in Rio than we
did in London, is that correct?
OWEN SLOT: Yeah.
So the book at one
stage was going
to be called "66 and 121."
The reason being that,
in London, Great Britain
won 65 medals in the Olympics
and 120 in the Paralympics.
And UK Sport put up this
target in their offices,
about four months later,
after the London Games, which
was 66 and 121, which
is basically our target
is to do better than
we did in London.
And there were people,
observers, myself included,
just sort of shaking
heads and going, you know,
you don't have to do that.
Why would you set yourself--
the level of astonishment at
Britain's success at the London
Games was higher.
You know, they did
much better than anyone
expected them to do.
So why take that and
try to aim higher?
And I guess it's one of those
things that in all businesses
you set targets.
But most people set targets
that they think they generally
can hit, but no one
generally thought they
could hit that target in Rio.
DAVID BENSON: Yeah.
OWEN SLOT: But as you say,
that there is a pattern that,
if you're a host of an
Olympic games, then,
naturally, your host country
wants you to do well.
So there is financial
input put into your teams
and your sporting systems.
And so host teams
generally tend to build up
in the Olympics towards
their home games,
peak at their home games.
And no one's done better.
Everyone's hit the peak
at their home games,
and gone down the other side.
And Australia's the
sort of classic example,
who were fourth in Sydney
at their home games.
By the time they got to
Beijing, they were eighth.
And then they were
10th in London.
And they were 10th in Rio again.
So they just followed the
classic parabola of up one side
and down the other.
And people running
the British team,
UK Sport, in particular,
they were just
saying, that is
what we want to--
we are just dead-set
on avoiding that.
We think it would be
the greatest achievement
to have done what
we did in London
and then do better afterwards.
DAVID BENSON: Sustain
that success, amazing.
So the book's
absolutely chock full
of great stories
of how they changed
things, how they found people.
Perhaps, let's dig
into some of those.
Give me one of your favorite
stories of success in the book.
OWEN SLOT: Well, OK.
So one of the people,
one of the interviews
that really, really stuck
with me from the book
was an interview with
a swimmer, now a coach,
called Mel Marshall.
And she went to the Athens
Games in '04 as the number one
in the world for
200-meter freestyle.
And she's a great, great
personality, real sort
of punchy, effervescent girl.
She always used to say that,
when she retired from swimming,
she was going to
be a firefighter.
She wasn't scared of anything,
a take on the world type.
It was just a real
pleasure to meet this girl.
So, as I say, she went
to Athens as the favorite
for the gold medal.
In her heat, she had sort of
quite a scratchy performance,
but she got through
to the semifinal.
And in the semifinal,
she came last,
so end of games, just
sudden, complete,
go home, whole thing
over, dream dies.
Your four years' preparation
for your big moments are over.
And when I spoke to her, she
was just astonishingly candid
when she said that
she kind of knew
she wasn't going to win
before she even got there.
She talked about the stress
that was brought down
from her performance
director and then her coach.
And she said she thought--
she guessed she was physically
and mentally drained
before she even arrived.
And then she went
into coaching herself.
At the same time,
British swimming
was probably the
standout failure
amongst British sports
during the years leading up
to London and London as well.
So in the decade
leading up to London,
British swimming had had total
investment of 52 million quid.
And that was second
only to athletics,
I think, so a huge investment.
Of that, 52 million
pounds was spread
over a total of 282 athletes,
some getting a bigger
share if they were
potential gold medalists.
If they were sort of at
the start of the pathway,
you get a smaller share.
But 52 million over 282
swimmers, and, of 282 swimmers,
total number of gold
medalists it produced was one.
So after--
DAVID BENSON: Terrible
return on that one.
OWEN SLOT: Terrible return.
So London was a great success.
The significant
failure was swimming.
So for Mel Marshall's
failure in 2004,
there had been a sequence
of management changes.
So you'd have an Olympics
failure, management change.
They started bringing
in coaches from abroad,
bringing new ideas,
et cetera, et cetera.
So there was a cycle of
change, cycle of change.
So there was no
cohesion, no consistency,
and nothing seemed to work.
And then, after London,
again, another change.
They brought in
this English guy,
called Chris Spice, who'd worked
in different sports before,
wasn't a swimming specialist.
And his appointment
was in place just
before the world championships
a year later in 2013.
So he arrived just before those.
And he only really went
in an observational role,
because no time to
make any changes
or work out what
he wanted to do.
So he watched what
happened there.
At those world
championships, Great Britain
won one bronze medal.
And he said to me,
his quotes were,
"I was staggered by the
level of under-performance.
I was staggered by the
amount of stress brought down
by the coaches."
And so that was from '04 to
'13, nine years the same culture
of fear and stress
amongst the performers.
So Spice did two things.
He said, how come we're spending
52 million on 282 people
and getting one gold medalist?
He said, do we really
know what a good swimmer
or a potential gold
medalist looks like?
Do we know where
we can spot them?
At what stage should you
be able to spot someone
who could win a gold medal?
Do we know what the age
profile for a gold medalist
is and not just in
swimming overall?
But there are 34 different
events in swimming,
so is there a different age for
a sprinter or a longer distance
swimmer?
At what stage should a swimmer
reveal himself or herself
as a potential gold medalist?
At what stage do
they have to have
been working with a top coach?
How many lengths
or what distance
should they swim or someone swim
a week, a month, or whatever?
So he had all these questions.
And he commissioned
this big data study,
took on two sport scientists
and effectively said,
you know, give me these answers.
Because we've got
282 swimmers, and we
don't know really who it is.
And these two sports
scientists eventually
brought him just tons and tons
of answers and stats and data.
But they said to him,
actually, your number is nine.
He said, how nine?
What does nine mean?
They said, well, it's
our belief that there
are nine swimmers
in this country that
could become gold
medalists in the Rio Games.
So that was quite
a startling thing
when you think how
many other people he'd
been funding at that time.
So he took the decision, OK,
let's really strip it back.
Let's take those nine.
They became known in the inner
circle as the golden nine.
And the funding was totally
restructured around them.
They didn't cut
off everyone else,
but quite a few people were cut
or their funding was shrunk.
And, basically, everything
was given to the golden nine
to just see if we've got these
top people, what can we get out
of them.
At the same time, he knew
that his coaching structure
was wrong.
His management was
wrong in so far
as the coaches were
bringing all this stress
down on their athletes.
And part of the
reason was because,
like in many walks of life,
if your team's not doing well,
then someone's
going to pay for it.
And especially in sports,
where you're so accountable,
if your athlete's
not doing very well,
then the coach might
not keep his job.
So amongst fellow
coaches who should all
have been working for the
same thing, which was success
amongst British
swimmers, they started
competing for each other,
not sharing information,
becoming terribly protective.
And so he brought in
someone to coach the coaches
and change the whole
culture of the coaching.
And one of the
coaches that benefited
was Mel Marshall,
who absolutely loved
this new environment of growth
and education and learning.
And so we get to Rio.
There is the great culmination.
So of the golden nine, as
they were, six of the nine
made it into the British team.
Four of the nine
won medals in Rio.
And one of them
was Adam Peaty, who
happened to be the kid who
was coached by Mel Marshall.
So from 2004 to that,
I thought was just
a wonderful turnaround.
DAVID BENSON: Yeah.
I mean, that's an amazing
story, because it's
a good example of how the
book covers everything.
It's about data and analysis.
It's about funding the big bets.
There's a lot of leadership
and psychological safety
and the trust that gets
built up with coaches.
OWEN SLOT: Yeah.
Yeah.
DAVID BENSON: And you really
feel that coming through,
which is the relationship
between these elite athletes
and their coaches.
It's almost-- I
mean, I've got kids.
And I think the bond
between the coaches
and the athletes
is almost stronger
than that in some senses.
The role of the coach
and the athlete,
how did he go about
changing that?
He brought in a rugby--
OWEN SLOT: Yeah.
So the guy he brought in--
DAVID BENSON: --coach to
the coaches, didn't he?
OWEN SLOT: Yeah.
The guy he brought in
to coach the coaches
had no history in
swimming at all.
But he had a back
where he played rugby
for England and
the British Lions
and, post-rugby, had
qualified as a rugby coach
and then started moving
into high performance
more generally.
And so his specialism was
in coach management, if you
like, management consultancy.
So he was brought in
with a fresh set of eyes.
And he said, himself,
his first meeting
with some of these
coaches, he could
see them looking at him
going, hey, you know,
nothing about swimming.
What's all this about then?
And then he started
this conversation
about how we could
help each other.
And he said, one of the coaches
just put his hand up and said,
I'm not sharing my
information with anyone else.
And he said, are you serious?
You think that you can
be better on your own
rather than with 20 of the best
swimming brains in the country?
So he slowly had to
break down that culture.
And I think one of the
things from that which
can be sort of applied to life
outside of a swimming pool
is he introduced the
idea that it wasn't just
the athletes that
could be a benchmarked.
So, obviously, if you're a
swimmer, then your times'
in the pool, you know,
it's on a stopwatch.
Everyone knows how good you are,
day by day, over a four year
period.
And so it was the swimmers
that were being benchmarked.
And he persuaded the
coaches that, actually, they
were performers
themselves, and that they
should be benchmarked, as well.
And it wasn't just the
success of their athletes
that was being watched.
It was their own performance
and their own demeanor.
And probably all of them
had swum to a decent level,
themselves, at some stage.
So this triggered their
own competitive instinct
of how they could improve,
rather than just handing down
what they thought were the
fruits of success, the seeds
of success, to their athletes.
It was we have to
improve ourselves.
And I think that
is something that's
still in British
swimming is the idea
that just because you make
it as a coach, that's not it.
You improve all the time.
DAVID BENSON: Yeah.
So there's sort of
continuous improvement.
OWEN SLOT: Yeah.
DAVID BENSON: Sort
of within the book,
you actually debunk a lot
of conventional wisdom.
So there's this-- we've
all heard of, you know,
10,000 hours.
And you've got to do 10,000
hours to master a subject.
But, actually, you've
got a number of examples
where that's debunked.
OWEN SLOT: Yeah.
So one of the challenges I have
with the book was my editor
wanted it to be a success
manual, if you like.
And you've probably seen quite
a lot of those sort of books.
And a lot of them
are really good.
But what he really,
really wanted
from me was an answer, a
sort of how to be successful,
so he could put it on the
front cover, like grit
or 10,000 hours or genetics.
Or what is the secret, you know?
How you part your
hair or whether you
work for Google or
something, is that what
actually makes you successful?
And that was, obviously,
in part a marketing tool.
But there are so many
books that are out there,
at the moment, that say,
if you do this one thing,
then you become successful.
And I had a massive
struggle with that.
Because, though I tried
to please my editor
and deliver what
he wanted, the fact
is that, if you're writing about
27 gold medals or whatever,
you've got 27 different stories.
And as I started saying
to him, after a while,
we're just kidding
our readers if we're
going to tell them there is
one thing that all these 27
people did that's collective,
that is your secret to success.
And so it's not just
your 10,000 hours,
or it's not just
your leadership,
or your environment,
or your talent ID,
it's all these things.
But if we get to tell all these
stories in a different way,
then actually it's 101
different things, which I think
is actually more interesting.
It doesn't give
you the opportunity
to put one simple answer
on the book and say,
success is straightforward.
I mean, it would be boring
if winning a gold medal
was as simple as just follow
Owen Slot's Book of A to Z,
and, probably, in
the first chapter,
we can tell you how to do it.
DAVID BENSON: Well, I was
obviously disappointed, myself.
OWEN SLOT: You know,
it's very complicated.
Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
DAVID BENSON: Sorry.
OWEN SLOT: It's just a
very complicated thing.
And especially in
British Olympic sport,
which, as I was
say before, you've
got some sports, like rowing,
where people have been winning
medals from way back, and they
have a sophisticated system
and are expected to
win a lot of medals,
to you're sort of start-up
companies, like trampolining,
for instance, which won
one medal out of nowhere,
or diving, for instance,
where Great Britain never
won anything, and now we won
a gold, silver, and a bronze
in Rio.
Or gymnastics, you know,
the British gymnastics team
were sort of the joke
amongst the high performing
world until 2004.
Then suddenly, 2008, out of
nowhere, a silver medal's
won by a kid called Louis Smith.
And then in 2012, there's
a team medal that's won.
And Beth Tweddle wins the
first female gymnastics
medal for ages.
And then in Rio,
two gold medals won
within an hour of each other.
DAVID BENSON: Yeah.
OWEN SLOT: And that's
just come from nowhere.
And they're all different.
And they're all stories of
how talented people became
the best in the world.
DAVID BENSON: So one
of the stories I really
liked in the talent
ID was it really
feels that part of
that success story
is actually finding
the right people
and the talent to put
into that pipeline--
OWEN SLOT: Yeah.
DAVID BENSON: --in
the beginning.
And there were some really
interesting ways in which
they found that talent.
So one of them was this
chap went to a university.
And he literally put two
pieces of colored tape
next a door, a red and a
blue, at certain heights.
And if you were taller
than that, he went,
you'd be a good rower.
OWEN SLOT: Yeah.
DAVID BENSON: And, you
know, red for women
and blue for men, basically.
OWEN SLOT: Yeah.
DAVID BENSON: And then
he would just literally
walk up to these students as
they picked up their student
cards to say, have you
ever thought about rowing?
That's an amazing
leap, isn't it?
I mean, he's literally casting
that net really broadly.
Are there any other,
sort of anecdotes
where you think
someone really just
did something very different
in order to source that talent?
OWEN SLOT: Yeah.
I mean, they pushed their
areas of learning to work out
how to find successful people.
I mean, so for me, one of
the complete culture changes
in British sport,
from '96 to now,
is, in '96, pretty
much the only way
you could become a medalist,
a British Olympic medalist,
was if you found your
own way to the top.
So if you happened to
be put into a sport,
through your school or your
parent's enthusiasm, whatever,
and you happened
to be good at it,
and you happened to find the
right coach at the right time,
then you might happen to
find your way to the top.
Whereas, over the next
20 years, the sort
of the culture completely
changed, which was, let's
not just feed off
those happy accidents,
where we find
people who are good,
let's just go looking for them.
So it was like, let's work
out what good looks like
rather than let's just do the
best of what good comes to us.
So in the diving,
for instance, I
loved the way they
did it with diving.
So the question was, what
does a good diver look like?
And one of the straightforward
answers to that is a good diver
looks Chinese, because
the Chinese divers
tend to win 80% of the gold
medals over the previous 20
Olympics.
Well, that's good to know.
So how do we feed off that?
Well, just so happened that, in
the sort of early '00s, there
was a Chinese elite diving camp
at Crystal Palace diving pool,
every year.
They used to do a
week's camp there
before one of the big
European competitions.
And so UK Sport said to
the Chinese diving people,
you can come and use Crystal
Palace, still, as your camp,
if we can come and do a
research project with you.
So they go, OK,
that's fair enough.
So the Chinese divers come in.
And the talent ID
person of British diving
goes and meets the
divers and does
a complete physiological
study on size, arm length,
leg length, the
whole sort of thing,
asked about their background,
their history, when
they got started
coaching, basically got
the full map of what a gold
medal diver could look like,
brought that back,
tried to work out
what that would look
like if you put it
into a seven or eight-year-old.
And then from then on, they did
a massive talent ID program,
very, very specific.
You had no chance of
being on it unless you
live within a 20-mile radius of
a diving pool in the country.
So if you lived
near Crystal Palace
or if you lived near Plymouth
or if you lived near Leeds, then
you'd have got a chance.
And they went into the schools.
And they got them to
do these tests to see
if they could be anything like
what these Chinese divers were
like.
And then, funnily enough,
Tom Daley came from Plymouth.
That's where he was found.
And then the result was seen
in Rio where, as you say,
we got a gold medal, a silver
medal, and a bronze medal
from a talent ID program that
had started 12 years earlier.
DAVID BENSON: Well,
that's an amazing story.
And it sort of applies
to us, because it's
like, understand
what good looks like
and what you need to do the job.
OWEN SLOT: Yeah.
DAVID BENSON: And
then go and define
where are you going to go
and find those people that
fit the profile to do the job.
OWEN SLOT: Yeah.
DAVID BENSON: And
actually removing
all of those biases,
which is the good divers
will have come up through
the old traditional roots.
OWEN SLOT: Yeah, because
their mum or dad said,
let's go and try diving.
DAVID BENSON: Yeah.
OWEN SLOT: Yeah.
DAVID BENSON: And, in
fact, some of these people
had never been diving
before until they got put
through this program.
OWEN SLOT: Yeah.
And their testing
program didn't require
them to go near water, either.
It was sort of jumping or
different things, you know?
The water was sort
of a side track.
DAVID BENSON: Yeah.
Well, one of the particular
ones I love-- just
to share it with the room to
tease you to buy the book--
was for the taekwondo
team, where, again,
were incredibly successful.
OWEN SLOT: Yeah.
DAVID BENSON: It
was literally just,
can you do 35 head
kicks in a minute?
And if you could, you
were in the program.
OWEN SLOT: Yeah.
DAVID BENSON: And, we
excel in taekwondo now.
OWEN SLOT: Yeah.
DAVID BENSON: It's
some amazing stuff.
Let's talk a little bit
about the translation.
This is, first and foremost,
an amazing read on what goes on
and how we succeed
in the Olympics.
But there is transition
and translation
to business and things we can
all do to achieve performance,
I guess.
As you said, there's
no simple formula.
OWEN SLOT: Yeah.
DAVID BENSON: But how should
we think about ourselves maybe?
Because we are both--
this is all about helping
athletes achieve success.
OWEN SLOT: Yeah.
DAVID BENSON: Should
we see ourselves
as the athletes or the
coaches or a bit of both?
How do we start to
translate from this sort
of elite sporting environment
into our world, do you think?
OWEN SLOT: Well, I'd say
everyone's an athlete, really.
Even, right to the top, you're
a performer in your own way.
And I think that's where
swimming went wrong,
for so long, is the
coaches forgot that they
were performers, themselves.
I think everyone
is the performer.
What I like about
what UK Sport did
is they went into
different businesses,
if you like, and
tried to work out
how and why they were
performing and how they
could be performing better.
And one of the stories
that I really like
is a Paralympian
called Dave Henson.
He was an Afghanistan soldier.
He was in the Royal Engineers.
February 2011, he
stepped on a mine
and lost best part
of one of his legs.
Two years later,
he was back at home
and was taken to a
talent ID center.
And this sort of rather
cute little idea that you're
a servicemen, now
you're injured,
therefore, you could
be a Paralympian.
So for London 2012, there
was a whole program,
which took injured
servicemen into London 2012.
And the theory was
quite good, if you like.
So if you're a serviceman
or servicewoman,
and you've served the British
Army or the Armed Forces,
then you are, one,
highly trained.
That's part of the deal.
Therefore, you're
highly trainable.
And also, the chances are that
you're reasonably athletic,
because you probably have done
some quite athletic things.
So, therefore, we
think that you lot,
who have been injured
in Afghanistan or Iraq,
could become Paralympians.
In London, there was one guy
who won two silver medals.
But afterwards,
the thinking was,
we didn't get quite the
return from these people
that we thought we should do.
And because it's a
sensitive subject,
because it was Paralympics,
and because you're
dealing with injured
servicemen, it
would be very easy for them to
have just carried on as they
were, getting mediocre success.
Two silver medals is
not such a bad thing.
They could have carried on
with the program as it was.
But they took the decision
to strip it right back
and ask why weren't we doing
as well as we should have done.
And they went and talked
to all the servicemen
who had become Paralympians and
asked about their experience.
And they found two
really crucial things.
One was-- what these
serviceman said
was, when we were
in the army, say,
or whatever squadron
we were in, we're
taught to go at the pace
of the slowest person.
You all go at the pace
You look after the slowest
man or the slowest woman
in your team.
And now, suddenly, we've
become Paralympians.
And we're told we're supposed
to kick-ass every day
and not wait for anyone, because
we've got to beat everyone.
And that whole sort of frame of
thinking was totally different.
But even more
significantly, they
worked out the
really brutal truth
that no single serviceman,
who ever went to Afghanistan
or Iraq, ever had
this dream of being
a Paralympian, funnily enough.
Everyone who's been in the
Olympics, at some stage,
it's been their dream probably
from when they were a kid.
That was the ultimate.
But no one in the army ever
wanted to be a Paralympian.
So they had to strip
it back and understand
exactly what was the motivation
of these men and women, who
they could take to
the Paralympics.
And so they completely
redesigned the program
around the psychology of what
was in it for these people
to go to the Paralympics.
And they worked out that
the Paralympics was just
a real secondary driving force.
So they wanted to
be Paralympians, A,
for their own self-esteem.
B, because they thought that
might help them as role models
to their kids, C,
because they just
saw sport as a way of helping
them become fitter and stronger
again.
And so, for every single
person, Paralympic success
was secondary to something else.
So at the back of
that, they managed
to sort of psychologically
understand what
was the driving force.
Instead of just
saying, we know how
to make success in
Paralympics or we
know how to make you go faster,
they had to go to the athletes
and say, we want you to tell
us why you want to do this,
and then we'll work
around you instead.
And so, as you say, if you want
to put that into a business,
they just stripped
back the whole thing
and went, well, why
wasn't it working well?
What did everyone actually
want to achieve out of this?
And how can we
improve this to do so?
DAVID BENSON: Yeah.
And then that to me, again, is
a really helpful learning, which
is you can lead a project.
But actually to really
drive a successful team,
you've got to understand
the motivations of all
the individuals in that team.
And what does good
look like for them--
OWEN SLOT: Yeah.
DAVID BENSON: --as well as,
you know, good for yourself?
I'm going to open this
to the floor in a second.
But I do have one more
question, and then I
do have a backup, as well.
But because we're
Google, there's
a large part of this book which
is about innovation in tech.
OWEN SLOT: Oh, yeah.
DAVID BENSON: You
know, I didn't know,
but there were 140 projects
involving Formula 1
engineers and all kinds of
engineers to actually improve
the technology of our athletes,
so rebuilding the bikes,
designing the sleds, et cetera.
Just so you know, part of you
sort of goes, is this fair?
Right?
But every other country
is also doing this.
So can you maybe
give us an example
of what was sort of the
biggest wows in terms
of the technological
innovation that went into that?
And how did we succeed in
bringing that tech innovation
to the games?
OWEN SLOT: Yeah, sure.
So, for me, the model in
this is British cycling.
Maybe not so surprising, because
there's so much tech involved
in a bike, in a skin suit,
in a helmet, in the shoes.
There's so many bits that
have to be aerodynamic
and can be
aerodynamically improved.
And so when British cycling
started getting competitive,
it realized that there
were significant gains
to be made from
competing in this area,
as well as having super fit,
super good cyclists themselves.
So there was a program
that started in the lead up
to the '08 Games, if you like.
And they gathered together
a really elite group
of mega-brains, if you like.
They went round.
They didn't just look
within British cycling
or British cycling coaches.
They went out to the military.
They went out to
textile industries.
universities and tried
to recruit a group of
disparate intellects
that could come together,
say, once a month
or once every six months,
just to pool ideas.
Well, have you
thought about this?
Have you thought about that?
So it was a way of tapping
into the bigger work
force or the bigger intellect
in the country, if you like.
So they did that.
So in '08, they produced
faster bikes, faster kits.
And when you talk
to them about that,
they said that
was like gathering
the low-hanging fruit.
Because they found that, because
of the way they'd done this,
they were better than
the opposition countries.
So 2012 came along, and
the opposition countries
had seen what Great
Britain had done,
knew that this was a
real area of competition
that they had to compete in.
But still, Great Britain
were ahead in that respect.
The low-hanging fruit was
sort of harder to find
or higher-hanging fruit.
So by the time they got
to the Rio cycle, again,
how could we use research
and technology and innovation
to improve the speed
of our cyclists?
And they went, OK, so we
think the marginal gains
that we can make, from a more
aerodynamic bike or helmet
or whatever, are so small that
we need to look elsewhere.
And so they took a shift that I
suspect the other nations will
take for the next
Olympiad, which they went,
so it's not stuff.
It's not kit.
It's how can we train better.
So, for me, it's just this
phenomenally smart thing
they did.
And it all came from a survey
they did with the athletes.
What helps you perform well?
What's impeding
your performance?
And they came down to this
slightly awkward subject
of saddle sores.
And they did a survey
of the saddle sores.
And they worked out,
one, that people
felt awkward about
discussing it,
especially the female
riders, which is probably not
really surprising.
And then they were
staggered also
to find out how many
days training were
missed due to saddle sores.
And also, further to that,
because no athlete wants
to miss a training
session, because that looks
bad on their
record, the athletes
have acknowledged,
well, one day a month,
my training's not as
good as it should be,
because I'm training
that day when I'm
suffering from saddle sores.
And so instead of trying
to make the bike fast,
they tried to work out how
can we solve that problem.
And the solution was
just phenomenally simple.
There are rules in
cycling on your saddle,
which the angle of the
saddle, it could only be flat
or 2 degrees dipped
going that way.
They worked out, if they dipped
it by a further 7 degrees,
then the whole problem would
be dramatically solved.
And they went to the governing
body of cycling and said,
listen, this isn't for
us, it's for everyone.
But we reckon we can make our
cyclists healthier and happier
by doing that.
The whole thing was approved.
No other country knew about it
even though it was written up
in the UCI document.
And so the success
continued in Rio.
And I can't tell you
how much, but, for me,
that was just like--
I mean, sometimes
the best innovations
and the most satisfying ones
are the simplest, aren't they?
DAVID BENSON: Yeah.
Absolutely.
OWEN SLOT: And that was
certainly one of those.
DAVID BENSON: Absolutely.
So this has been fascinating.
The book has got so many
more examples like that.
It is mind-blowing.
But I just want to open
the questions to the floor.
AUDIENCE: Hi, there.
Thanks very much for your time.
I was really interested in the
golden nine you spoke about.
OWEN SLOT: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Obviously, you said
there was hundreds of swimmers,
and they found these nine.
And then they invested
all the money into it.
How did they find these
nine, what metrics?
Can you give us some
insight into the specifics
of how they chose these nine?
How do they recognize
that talent?
What techniques, what
analysis, did they do?
And how could we then
use that to spot talent
in the business context?
OWEN SLOT: Sure.
It was largely about just
following an athlete's-- excuse
me--
pathway.
So they looked a lot at the
two most successful swimming
nations, Australia
and the United States.
And they looked to all
their gold medalists.
And they worked out how--
so if you took, say, Michael
Phelps, for instance,
the most famous
swimmer in the world.
So they would
follow his pathway.
And they would work out at what
stage was he showing himself
as an outstanding swimmer.
And how good do you have
to be at that stage?
So, for instance,
Great Britain has had--
still has, but had--
a pretty successful junior team.
And so we were thinking, well,
we've got these good juniors.
Therefore, we'll fund them and
take them on into the seniors,
and they should be successful.
But the more research
they did into it,
they saw that actually the
correlation between being great
at the age of 14 and 22
doesn't really exist.
So they did that comparison
across those two countries.
And so for each of
those 34 events,
they sort of worked
out a timeline
and a pathway of what your
swimmer has to look like.
At what point can you tell
that they might reach that?
And they saw that
it was pretty late.
And then they saw,
at that point,
at what point do they have
to be with a good coach.
And so they put all that
information in and tracked it
back and saw, well, who's
in that position now.
AUDIENCE: All right, thanks.
So it was more about
physical traits
rather than, like,
measurable lung
capacity or speed of
reps, that kind of stuff?
OWEN SLOT: Well,
it would have been
their performance in the pool.
So, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Just following
on that question--
why do you think other
countries couldn't do that?
OWEN SLOT: Why they couldn't?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So whatever metrics we talked
about, that's very public,
right?
OWEN SLOT: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So any country,
let's say China or India,
can also go and look
at the US metrics
and think, oh, I
could also do that.
So what is the difference that
we did that others couldn't do?
Or have you researched
into that or you thought?
OWEN SLOT: I think
what Great Britain did,
which was different, was--
as you say, other
people can work that out
if they're prepared to put
the time and effort into it.
It's not insurmountable.
But it was the way that they
invested so heavily in such
a small group of people.
So they really, really backed
themselves to do it that way
and identified who that was.
And I think-- so it
sounds quite simple.
But, at the time, when
the British team did it,
it was controversial.
And so, for instance, the best
British swimmer at the time
was a young man
called Liam Tancock.
And he was a double
world champion.
He won the Commonwealth Games.
So he was kind of like the face
of British swimming almost.
But they followed
sort of his time line.
And they saw, well, by
the time you go to Rio,
you're actually going
to be 32 years old.
And so we think that
takes you way out
of reach of what could
potentially win a gold medal.
And so they cut his
funding altogether.
And so, that's
effectively saying
we decided to cut the
funding of our best athlete.
So I think it was
as much the bravery
to push it to the
extreme as anything else.
AUDIENCE: Here and then over--
AUDIENCE: Hi, thank you.
I'm halfway through the book.
It's a fantastic
read, even for those
who don't enjoy sport too much.
And I'm conscious, both in
the book and in your answers,
you're sort of a
bit reluctant to go
too far into lessons for
business and the rest of us.
But I wondered.
You know, you've been covering
this story for a long time.
It's an amazing turnaround.
If you were looking at your
own professional life, editor
of "The Times" or
Rupert Murdoch,
what would you do differently
and apply from those lessons
to your world?
OWEN SLOT: Shit.
[LAUGHTER]
OK.
Now, that's really interesting.
So if I was to apply that to
what I did, then I would be--
so if I was following
that to the extreme,
I would be looking at
what the successful sports
writers did, which I think
is something I did do.
So I wanted to be
a sports writer.
So I used to hoover up
the best sports writing,
all the sports writers I
really liked and looked
at how they reported, how
they wrote, et cetera.
So to answer your question,
what I should then be doing
is going, well, what
happened to the best sports
writers when they got
to a decent position?
So I was sent to cover
Olympics age of 28.
I thought, Christ, I've made it.
And so what happens next?
I was really happy to be there.
But some sports
writers then went on
to becoming news reporters,
foreign correspondents.
Some went to become
sports editors.
And then the guy who took
me on at "The Times,"
he was the sports editor.
He went on to become the deputy
editor of "The Times," and then
deputy news editor of the BBC.
So maybe I should be looking
at their pathways and going,
you know, how or
why did they do it?
I mean, I did want to be a
sports editor for a while.
And I probably
never cracked what
it was that was
their talent that I
should have been pushing.
AUDIENCE: Hi, thank you.
That was really interesting.
So I used to work for
a venture capital firm.
And one of the projects
I was looking at
was how can we spot founders
before they're founders.
So how can you start to
look at founder attributes?
Do you think you can apply any
of the thinking or methodology
to kind of early start-up
founders or those
within that kind of high
growth technology sector?
OWEN SLOT: So, I apologize.
Can you explain founder?
Do you mean a founder
of a start-up company?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Yeah.
So the company would invest in
kind of later-stage founders,
but we were trying
to work out, can we
spot prospective
founders, either when
they are at university or
when they are at school,
and then hone their talent.
So I was wondering
if you could apply
any of that kind of thinking to
founders or technology leaders.
OWEN SLOT: Yeah.
I think-- so, one
of the chapters
that I was interested in,
in the book, was shooting.
So, again, shooting was
maybe not far off a start-up,
if you like.
They didn't win very much.
And they wanted to
know how to do better.
And for the shooting
team, UK Sport
brought in someone
from private equity,
who was a professional
in investing in start-ups
and also turning
around companies
and working out how can
we apply that to sports.
And they tried to take those
very philosophies to shooting.
And I guess the
founder that they
brought in there was the guy
who became chief executive of--
sorry, performance director
of British shooting.
And he was encouraged to
try to address shooting as
if it was a start-up company.
And so he wrote a performance
plan and very much along
business terms of how we can do
it and how far we can achieve
and how we're going to do that.
And his first business
plan was sent right back
to him saying you've not
been ambitious enough.
So one of the things that--
yeah.
So one of the elements that UK
Sport are always looking for
is people to lead sports.
I think they're better now
at finding athletes than they
are at finding leaders.
And they have got to
the point where they're
trying to talent ID
for prospective leaders
as well as prospective
Olympic gold medallists.
DAVID BENSON: Brilliant.
Well, look, I think
we're out of time.
And we could carry on
forever, but people
have got to get to meetings.
So, Owen, I just
want to say thank you
very much, both for a fantastic
session and an amazing book.
So if we can have everyone
give him a round of applause,
that would be great.
OWEN SLOT: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]